[Musik]
brauchten schatz sagen
sag nicht immer sagen
aber was soll ich anstelle von sagen
sagen
sag nicht immer sagen
aber was soll ich anstelle von sagen
sagen
ich gebe dir ein paar beispiele
der polizist droht
wenn ich sie nochmals erwischt bezahlen
sie eine buße
der lehrer lobt
bravo diesen text hast du gut
geschrieben
die kinder bestehen
die kinder besteht
em
ja wir haben dich
beim fußballspielen zerbrochen
ja wir haben
fußballspielen zerbrochen
vernichte ich meine
nicht auch dadurch dass ich sie zu
freunde mache
vernichte ich meine feinde nicht auch
dadurch dass sich die zu freunde mache
der fahrt
seine söhne auf
der vaart
fordert seine söhne auf
lest bitte diese abfälle auf und wirft
sie in den eimer
lest bittet diese abfälle auf und wirft
[Applaus]
die ganze mannschaft jubelt
die ganze mannschaft jubelt hurra wir
haben wir wollen
hurra wir haben gewonnen
der kapitän befiehlt
putzt das deck
putz das deck
peter
alt
peter prahlt
ich bin vom zehnmeterbrett gesprungen
[Musik]
die mutter mahnt
nun musst du aber wirklich die
hausaufgaben machen
ja ja gleich nur noch dieses level
nun musst du aber wirklich die
hausaufgaben machen
ja ja gleich nur noch dieses level
die mutter mahnt
rudi junior vergisst nicht die aufträge
für die schule zu erledigen
ja ja gleich ich schaue nur diese folge
von familie schröder zu ende
rudi junior vergiss nicht die aufträge
für die schule zu erledigen
ja ja gleich schaue nur dieser folge von
familie schröder zu ende
a
ach dieses homeschooling ist anstrengend
dieses homeschooling ist anstrengend
hast du mit der arbeit schon begonnen
ja ja gleich
home office bedeutet ein kind mehr zu
hause
paul spottet
eine kuh klettert ja noch besser als du
1 nach
red
sie hat fieber und halsschmerzen seit
gestern
der nachbar rät
ich spürte mit dem kind zum arzt gehen
ruf aber zuerst in der arztpraxis an
der nachbar rät
ich spüre mit dem kind zum arzt gehen
ruf aber zuerst in der arztpraxis an
ein lehrer klagt
der lehrer klagt
wenn hier nur nicht so viel schwarzen
würdet
wenn nur nicht zu viel schwarzen würdet
die apa
nachbar bemerkt
der
bemerkt
für maurer hat heute aber schlechte
laune
der maurer hat heute aber schlechte
kennst du noch andere synonym für sagen
schreib deine beispiele in den
kommentaren
[Musik]
www.hhl.de
ch
[Musik]
danke fürs schauen bitte leica das video
und abonniere unseren kanal
danke für schauen
mit der leica das video und abonniere
unseren kanal